okay
could you see my screen yes
okay sounds great um it's my great
pleasure to be here
uh to give another uta theme park after
school
so we are in this talk is about
a game related to safety safety learning
score just mentioned i will focus on a
specific topic
on how to constructing uh non
non-starting confidence balance for off
policy evaluation so we will propose a
uh what do we call optimization based
algorithm which is
uh framing the construction of
confidence intervals into a
optimization problem and we can apply
primal do uh methods to kind of solve it
efficiently
we'll see how how it goes um okay so
i guess i don't need to uh give a heavy
introduction to
the safety questions after
school's talk but basically the idea
here is that
reinforced learning has been really
powerful at cases when we have
very good simulators such as video games
and alphago right
but on the other hand for many real
world problems
we have um we don't have high volatility
simulators and we only have
observational data right
so this is especially the case we want
to apply reinforcement into medical
diagnosis education
robotics when the robotics are very
expensive and you don't want to damage
them
so in these cases you we only have data
observed from previous experiments
possibly in a very
messy unstructured and um
and unorganized way right so in this way
in this case the information about
system is very limited
so when you apply reinforcement lending
lots of uncertainty right you
you cannot ensure whether you are doing
the right thing right so
so here uncertainty estimation is really
important
especially in high stake areas such as
health care
it's actually not enough to just get the
arbitrary uncertain destination you
actually want to
make sure that your answered information
is theoretically
verified it's guaranteed it's rigorous
right this is why we are motivated to
uh to talk about uh non-asymptotic
balance instead of
approximation algorithms um so here's my
uh definition of the problem so the
problem is that
we are given a policy pi pie and
we want to construct a non-asymptotic
confidence interval
for the expected reward purely from
observational data right
so there are lots of challenges first of
all the data is on
off policy which means that it's
collected from some arbitrary
policy or even no policy right so
arbitrarily so so
if you want to reason about a particular
pie that
hasn't been tested before it requires
some sort of counterfactual reasoning
ability right
um another another another challenge is
that the data are collected in some
black box way which is unknown to the
algorithm right
so the algorithm has to be behavior
agnostic in order to
uh take that into account right
um and also uh as we are doing
reinforced lending we have
non trajectories and the trajectories
are dependent with each other across the
time
so we don't have the id assumption that
was very nice for
supervised learning but here we really
don't have that
uh and this actually caused a very
difficult strong difficulty for
uh for constructing as a target balance
right
and also uh that's a that's uh something
called a cursor horizon which means that
if you are reasoning about non-horizon
if your
decision making has lots of steps it's
very difficult to reason about future
rewards just because you are considering
uh
reasoning multiple steps mathematically
it turns out this is also very difficult
for traditional methods
right so these are these are kind of
challenging problems
but more or less we actually propose our
algorithm i think
quite nicely surprisingly solve all
these problems
um so we provided a non-isotonic bound
has guarantees and you know his behavior
agnostic
works for infant horizon it's off policy
actually works for data with arbitrary
dependencies
so it's very nice flexible and um
again the idea i would talk about that
it's a it's a
kind of optimization review um
when's when sort of primal do uh
flavor okay
so so so let's talk about the background
um
the setting is very simple and standard
we have a packing policy pi
which is giving we have uh unknown
environment
p is unknown to us so basically every
time
the agent take action based on state and
then based on the action state
uh you have an environment that tries it
into another state
st plus one also we receive the reward
right so both the way to
receive the reward and the next state
unknown to
to the user right to the algorithm
and we want to estimate the expected
reward over an
infant horizon which is summing over all
the time
up to infinite and of the reward
discounted by a factor gamma t
right starting from some initialization
mu zero right
as shown here we assume mu zero is fixed
is known as well okay so um
so so um now the problem is given
uh in reality we don't know the the true
model so we assume
that we have uh transition uh
pairs right so uh i can actually label
so so we have um we have we collected
a collection of transition pairs right
this is
uh i will talk about what's the
conditional transition has but basically
we observe
a bunch of things a data set and then we
want to
construct a confidence interval which is
a function of the data
such that the probability that the
confidence
interval catch the true value
the true expected reward is larger than
one minus delta
that has a confidence level right so
here the probability is taking with
respect to the randomness of data right
so the interval is around is a standard
confidence interval thing so the
interval is a random number versus the
the truly what is a fixed but want to
make sure the interval actually catch
the true value
with high probability right okay
um so this is our formal definition
of the data assumption it's actually a
very quite
mild assumption so the idea is that we
assume we
we collected a set of uh transition
pairs
right and we assumed the transition
pairs are collected
sequentially such that at each for each
data point i
the sa the state and action is collected
by
some arbitrary procedure that is unknown
to us
given the previous data points um
and then and then given the standard
action pair
uh the next state uh the next action
the the next state and the reward uh
is collected from the unknown true model
right so really the the requirement the
only requirement we have is that
uh the next state and the reward uh
given the previous state and action has
to follow the model the true
the underlying environment but otherwise
it can be arbitrary so the state
actually could be you could use it
any way to decide your essay at each
time
right so
so it's very flexible in fact i cannot
figure out the case when this is not
satisfied
the only case i can figure out is when
somehow there's a loopy
dependency where you can travel back to
time but that's
that doesn't seem to be realistic so
just a second um on this assumption a
quick question so you say that this data
is gathered
sequentially with this black box but
it's not very clear to me whether
you're assuming that these toppers would
be independent
of each other
so this is a sequential process right
you can think of it as a market
and so like is there going to be some
mixing assumption here because
there's no mixing assumption that's the
key right so maybe
i will i think on this slide it will
make it very much clear
so the idea is that you can kind of view
this as a
two-part setting i think this is really
a kind of shoot i think
i got it like you're gonna yeah yeah
yeah
yeah so so basically you can view as a
as as your feature
right and then your white as your label
right so it's like a supervisor and you
want to give an x you want to put in y
um and really what i'm assuming is that
why
given x follows the model but then i
don't assume anything about the data
right the data is collected arbitrary
this is really the kind of
uh uh kind of uh
supervised learning setting like well we
really don't need to assume the
uh uh what what the data comes from even
more
general right so the question i'm asking
whether the
ex eyes could be sequentially correlated
like
the blank yeah sequential equality they
could be deterministic they could be
the the black box might decide for
example that i like this previous xi
let's just go back
and let's speak that again and 100 times
more
and stuff like that right
yeah okay yeah sounds great um
so yeah the point again i think the
point is that uh
the data is really arbitrary right so uh
x i could be dependent
in some arbitrary fashion the idea is
that when we want to construct a
confidence bound we really
don't care about how the data was
generated we only care about
the information the data is carried to
me right so
like when you generate data you have all
kinds of assumptions right but once you
get the data
the data is fixed right so that we
really
we don't need to care about how the data
was generated because
by the time the data is given it's
already deterministic
um okay so
um a traditional way to
to construct non-aesthetic confidence
bounds
it seems that the only way to do this is
using
uh important sampling plus uh
concentration inequalities
this is that's a large literature very
classical
literature on this many of the people
here
are contributing heavily on this topic
and the
the idea is that you collect
uh a set of independent trajectories
from
uh from some known behavioral policy pi
zero
in this case you have to have multiple
trajectories that are independent
and you have to uh the trajectory has to
be drawn from some known
uh policy pi so it's not
arbitrary dependency right it doesn't
follow the assumption that i just
mentioned and also it's not behavior
agnostic right
and also you have to truncate the
horizons to be some finite horizon
in this case you can use a standard
important sampling estimator
and basically design weights on the
trajectories
and then you can get a concentration
bound using um
non-synthetic bond using any
constitutional equality right so
obviously there are lots of
uh drawbacks right uh it
doesn't so so actually it doesn't has
the
uh efficiency so when you when you have
a large horizon tee
this algorithm actually tends to
degenerate that's because your
importance weight is a product
over the time as you have lots of time
time goes to infinite
the variance of your importance rates
grow exponentially
so that's a very bad there's something
we call cursor horizon
and also this algorithm has to require
independent
assumptions between the trajectories if
you don't have
independent assumption you can still
give an estimation
but you cannot provide non-asymptotic
bound
without providing a bound over the
mixing coefficient of the macro
process right so as you want to
emphasize here is that our algorithm
doesn't require the mixing condition
um and also it's not behavioral plastic
right
so it doesn't work for our case um
there are obviously many other ways to
get confidence bounds for
uh off policy uh till there are
bootstrap algorithms
uh developed recently a school also had
a welcome list
but bootstrap is is a asymptotic uh
algorithm so it doesn't give nice and
other guarantees uh if we
care about safety we should be go with
niacin particle right because that's a
real guarantee
uh and there are also bayesian methods
that
quantify so many things for as many but
bayesian doesn't
have frequencies to coverage so it
doesn't have the kind of guarantee that
we wrote
right okay so how do we solve this
problem well
it starts from a line of work that i was
getting into
together with the home and many other
collaborators on
uh infant verizon value uh estimation
uh so we have a sequence to work on uh
estimating
uh the reward out first of all without a
confidence estimation uh for the
inference for us in case
when you have the cursor override cursor
horizon for important sampling
and then we talk about uh uh and
and then this civil war gradually moved
towards to
confidence bound estimation but it more
or less it provides a
foundation for my method so i want to
introduce this line of work
so it turns out that there are two major
algorithms for infinite horizon value
estimation
one is based on a q function another is
based on visitation distribution
so the q function idea is very simple
basically
if you can estimate the q function of
the policy
the q function is the cumulative reward
given that you start from a fixed
state action pair where here i'm using x
to represent the state action pairs
then you can if you know the q function
you can just take the average
expectation of your q function over the
initialization
over the initial states right that will
give your expected reward
this is one way to kind of think about
exactly reward another way
to think about reward is that you can
you can calculate what's called the
visitation distribution
which is the discounted average of the
of the distribution of the states across
time so here
uh d d pi t is the distribution of x t
if you run the policy
pi for two steps starting from
initialization
then you can get the estimation as well
so the expected reward is going to be
the expectation of the local reward
uh taking expectation under the type
right
so you can sort of see these two ways
different ways to calculate the expected
reward they're really just
they're duality each other they have a
primary deal relationship i will talk
about this
many people also observe that uh but i
think the difference is really that when
you talk about this summation over
infinite right
so when you uh have this q function
representation the
summation is pushing inside the reward
versus when you
have the visitation distribution the
summation is pushed into the probability
that two ways to kind of count the
summation um
okay but then if we can estimate either
with a visitation distribution uh
or q function we can we can construct
the
estimation like if we can extend those
we can use we can do
w bus destination right um okay so how
to estimate vegetation distribution
well uh uh it's uh uh we we had this
idea that
you can actually put some importance
weight
on on the data point so here w uh
is some weight distribution over the
data points right
we can actually define this weighted
empirical
distribution over the distribution where
each data point is assigned to when the
weight
uh and then we want to find the weight
such that
the weighted distribution of the data
actually follow
matches the uh the visitation
distribution right
if we can do this then we can
approximate um
approximate the expected reward using
the weighted sum
over the reward over the data set right
so this is
kind of like an important sampling but
we are applying important sampling
on the on the transition level and it's
for
implant horizon so the the importance w
here
doesn't have a closed form solution
doesn't have close form representation
and we actually need to uh estimate it
using using optimization methods right
um but the way we estimate it is to
define a reward function
um the reward function we defined it is
uh
is a minimax reward so the idea is that
uh so basically if you assume the the
policy for uh
uh given the policy that's markov chain
right you
essentially you are trying to estimate
the station distribution of the map of
chain
and then what you can do is you write
down the the fixed point
equation for the markov chain and we
reframe it a little bit
uh it turns out that you can show that
we can define this delta function
i don't want to get into detail about
what this function does but basically
this is a function that is fully
computable
you can directly calculate from the data
and then you can show that
this this delta function equal to zero
for n and q
here q is a kind of uh a a discriminator
function that we introduce
such that if if w if the dw is exactly
equal to the d
pi then then this delta equal to zero
for any distribution q right so
it quantifies the deviation of delta to
the the kind of true delta
uh deviation of w to the qw
right so in this way we can define this
uh worst case kind of
uh laws where you take a set of
q function as as a discriminator it's
kind of like a gang style
where you find the worst case q right
and if delta equal to zero for every q
then this loss function has to be zero
otherwise it will be positive if the q
is symmetric
um then this defines a loss function
and if we in addition if we choose q to
be a reproducing kernel hebrew space
it's a kernel space with a positive
definite column uh
uh related to this thing you think it's
uh doing some kind of kernel regression
then you can actually write down the
closed form solution for the loss
available
oh sorry do you have about four minutes
left oh four minutes left
okay so i need to do really quick okay
um uh so another approach is
to do a q function estimation uh
and again the idea is that we are going
to introduce uh
uh a kind of discrete loss and the
the loss is defined in this way we again
we use a minimax
loss function to uh to define the laws
and again we introduced a discriminator
function
uh if the discriminant function is a
chrono architectus we can actually show
that it has this code
very nice closed form um that
that can be calculated easily and and
and the further the the key
uh result that we have is that if the
data is collected following the
previous assumptions then we can show
that
the kernel loss of the true uh
q function uh is bounded by this
non-isotopic bounds
um and this is important basically uh
the the concentration equality actually
doesn't require any sort of dependency
among the independence of my exact right
so given this uh concentration
inequality
what we can do is we can construct this
uh this concentration
uh this feasible region for uh
for q function right so uh if we define
this function set well q is some model
space that is a prior information that
capture q q pi then this set has to
be a confidence set for the for the true
function
right it puts the non-synthetic
guarantee
and then we can actually transform this
feasible region of q pi
into a confidence interval for for the
expected reward by finding the extreme q
functions
either maximize it minimize it we will
get a confidence bound for
for for the expected reward right um
and this frames the optimization problem
which can actually be solved in practice
but the disadvantage is that we have to
solve this optimization to absolute
global optimal in order to guarantee our
methods
this is not ideal so what we did was to
derive
a upper bound of this of
this this confidence interval so so the
upper bound
is a minimization problem it's
guaranteed to be
uh larger than the bound that we have
and depends on some w
in fact if you look at the upper and
lower bound it has this very clear
primal dual structure where
the primal bond is framed as optimizing
q function
versus the the dual boundary is actually
framed as
optimizing the density ratio so
in fact you can sort of see the chrono
bomb and loss for q and here is the
density the loss for the uh dense
density ratio as well
right so uh now you can use for any w
you can actually construct the
confidence bounce in this way
it's like assigning an error bar around
the
density ratio estimation and we can
actually find the best of w by
minimizing
uh the the the loss right
in this case the idea is that you don't
have to solve the the thing
into global optimal solution you just
want to find whatever the best
because you will you will always
guarantee the one delta condition
it's just that uh if you optimize delta
better you will get a tighter bond
right okay so this is in fact our method
it's a very simple algorithm so
basically you
use find a density estimation uh
density ratio estimation by minimizing
this loss try your best you don't have
to
find the global optimal and then
construct your bomb in this way right
so so here's a few discussions i'm not
sure i will have time
but the idea is that our method actually
critically uh
based on the assumption that the q
function actually follows a
uh belongs to a family uh model family
it's very similar to
shuffle's menu where we have to assume
certain model family we cannot
do statistics without any assumption
right
it turns out we cannot actually uh put
positively verify the assumptions again
it's the same thing as as the statistics
well we cannot absolutely verify the
modal assumptions we can reject but we
can never absolutely satisfy
uh that so that's a modern specific uh
mis model miss specification problem and
we can actually show that even if we
cannot verify
that assumption we can still kind of
interpret our methods
as trying best as trying to uh get
uh upper bound of some kind of oracle
estimation
that is accessible given the data so i
wouldn't get detailed but if that's a
question i can explain more
um so we have some simple example here
so this is going to be the what it looks
like if you check the gap
between the the confidence intervals it
actually decays
nicely with the data so it's a
consistent algorithm um
these are a few uh comparisons with
other methods
uh so basically what we observe is that
so the green line is our method
right and if you use the important
sampling with concentration boundary you
will
guarantee non-asymptotics as well but it
will be much
looser than our bound and then if you
use other methods like the bootstrap for
example
you cannot guarantee nice and highly
bounce you
have the risk of not catching the true
value which is
if you have the nice entire guarantee
you can always uh
with hyper b catch the two values okay
so uh
i'm stopping here i'm sorry that if this
is over time
thank you so much i think there was uh
some uh some discussion some questions
from chaba about uh individual's
assumptions so i'll open the floor for
questions and we can start there
yeah uh hey uh very very nice
uh i read the paper a while ago and i
kept confusing myself about multiple
things i guess
uh maybe at a very high level you you
also said at the end
is that this realizability is highly
crucial and what you're doing is that
rather than
assuming that you would estimate the
model you just assume
that a function uh or features are given
to you maybe you can push it to infinite
dimensional
spaces what not but so you're given
these features
or arcade space and you assume
realizability
and that's the way you avoid the mixing
assumptions exactly
exactly i'm people would normally just
estimate a modern and based on the
estimated model
you can evaluate any policy and then you
can get confidence bonds uh
with that way as well uh by assuming
realizability in in a way but this way
you're kind of like
so you could do the same thing what i
want to say in linear mdps is changing
style linear mdps right
uh but uh then that's that's a little
bit
stronger than the assumption that you're
doing right and then
you kind of avoid estimating that you go
directly for
the action value function and you show
that everything
like including confidence intervals uh
work out uh super nicely which is which
is very neat
all right so with that let's let's make
this a question uh
so do you have any thoughts about like
what to do in the unrealizable setting
uh how bad is that i have some
dark thoughts about that uh
so do you mean the case when the um
the motor assumption doesn't uh doesn't
doesn't satisfy
it of course yeah yeah right so i think
this is very tricky question here's the
thing right so
we are taking the model space to be an
architecture space
it's a kernel space it's a infinite
dimensional so
um we can um so there will be two cases
one if the uh so we have the data is
given
and as i mentioned here we can actually
this is a very special thing about this
algorithm
what we can do is we can take the data
and just look at data
very carefully using any algorithm to
figure out a queue
and the queue can actually depend on
data in an arbitrary way this is unusual
this is what's different from the
entrepreneur's name so we can look at
the data and
construct the queue such that it's large
enough such that we cannot statistically
reject
the the assumption so there were no uh
modern misses specification
in this case the only difficulty here is
that
when i construct a very large queue such
that i cannot reject
my hypothesis i can still i can
i still cannot guarantee that my true q
will in fact be inside the queue that i
have
because this is this is because the us
data assumption that we had earlier
was really weak we didn't assume
anything about the distribution of the
state
so because of this weak assumption uh in
fact
statistically we cannot identify
uh case reject we cannot positively uh
decide
a case when when q is indeed uh uh
in the model space right so so we don't
have the model specific specific
uh problem we more like have the model
non-identifiability problem working
we cannot decide among set of models
given the
information that we have we
fundamentally cannot decide
uh the model but it's not about the
misses
simplification because if that's a
mysterious certification we can actually
reject that how does rejection work
exactly
so rejection uh is that you can
uh you can calculate the loss function
of of the functions inside the queue
inside your your distribution and the
order of cubes you must play you're
writing so i can't see it
yeah like you have to make that uh
the recording thing go away i don't know
whether it's on everyone's screen but or
write some other point
yeah right okay good oh okay that's
okay uh yes uh so the idea is that
uh you can calculate the kernel loss for
every q
inside of model space and if every
if that lower bound is large is large
then it will reject
basically if every data point if every
queue inside the function space
has a large kernel loss domain loss then
you reject it
okay so you basically say that there is
no way
i can support the data
uh with my function class then you say
that my
function class was not big enough is
that going to happen if you haven't
you know and a universal arcade space
yes but the problem is right uh
assume i have a function right so let's
say i'm thinking about super as a
learning problem
i haven't set a set of data points right
um
and i observe the value of uh on the
final number points and i want to feed a
curve right
if you don't have any assumption at all
about the curve you cannot learn
anything because what you observe
is on what you observe you
you can never extend your observation
your information to the points that you
don't observe
unless you make some assumption right
and that assumption cannot be verified
from data itself has to be verified
from as a prior knowledge right so for
example
in order to fit this curve i have to
assume that
the curve is sufficiently smooth so i
can i can do any kind of learning right
if i don't make any assumption that the
the model could be arbitrarily
uh kind of messy right so even if you
model that fits the data perfectly well
you you can never guarantee
anything about ouncing data unless you
have some sort of assumption
sure i was asking the other direction i
didn't know you were say that okay if
you assume smooth system obviously
if your data is very checky then you're
gonna say that okay
i reject it or something like that
okay um i think on this note
uh possibly we should unfortunately both
talk to
uh sorry chubba
but maybe we can continue just over the
chat thank you so much chunk for the
talk